Now we will look
the first law on thermodynamics.
But before we start with it,
you might be wondering,
"What is thermodynamics?".
You can think of the roots of the word.
We have "thermo" associated with thermal, connected with temperature.
And the dynamics - the properties of temperature,
how atoms are moving, what is the temperature behavior.
This is thermodynamics,
she studies the heat and temperature
and how they relate to energy and work.
How different types of energy
they move from one form to another.
That's what it's all about
the first law of thermodynamics we mentioned
in the introductory video on energy.
The first law of thermodynamics tells us that energy ...
this is important, I will write it:
the energy can not be created or destroyed.
Can not be created
or destroy.
It can only be transformed from one form into another.
Only,
only to become,
just to become ...
today I find it hard to write.
Energy can only turn
from one species to another.
Can be transmitted or converted from one species to another,
but it can not be created or destroyed.
The rest of the video
I want to give some examples to understand this law
and think about it
what is the energy that we observe in a system.
Then we will think of where this energy comes from,
to understand that he is not coming from anywhere
and that it does not disappear,
that it is not destroyed.
I'll start with an example of an electric bulb.
You can leave the video paused,
to think about the types of energy we see here.
And then - about where this energy comes from and where it goes.
The most obvious form of energy here,
the purpose of the bulb is the radiant energy.
You see electromagnetic waves and light,
which radiates.
This is radiant energy.
Radiant energy.
Radiant energy is produced
from the heated wire here.
When the electrons pass through it, they create heat,
we have heat.
We also have heat.
Heat energy.
But where does the radiant and thermal energy come from?
To repeat, the first law of thermodynamics tells us,
that energy is not created by nothing,
but is transformed from one species to another or transmitted from somewhere.
I told you this heat
comes from the movement of electrons through the wire.
They move through the wire that it has
resistance, it generates heat.
The electrons are moving through the wire like through
resistor and create heat.
So we have the kinetic energy of the electrons.
I will write KE (EC) to reduce kinetic energy.
The kinetic energy of electrons.
Where does it come from?
It comes from the potential energy.
It may be included in a contact.
I will draw an electrical outlet
right here.
If this one
an electrical outlet was in your home,
there would be an electrical potential between these two ends.
When making a connection,
the electrons can move.
We will go into details about the direct current
in the next videos. There is an electrical potential
between this and that point. Assuming this is the direction,
in which the electrons move.
So here the potential energy has turned
in the kinetic energy of electrons,
which takes the form of electric current,
which turns into heat
and radiant energy.
What happens next? Let's say we exclude the bulb from the socket,
the light goes out. What happens to all the energy?
Is he still there?
Yes, the thermal energy will continue
to distract the system.
Here is an open system,
The gas in the bulb - not fully visible,
but it looks like this.
The air will also warm up
will warm the bulb's glass,
and it will warm the outside air.
So the heat is turning
in the radiant energy that moves out.
It can become other forms
of energy, most often thermal,
so it will warm up other things.
What about this billiard table?
When I hit a ball, this one, for example.
Where will the energy go?
Part of the energy will hit the next
a ball that will hit the next.
But as we all know, if we played billiards,
at some point they will stop.
What has happened to their energy?
As they rolled,
there was air resistance.
Balls have struck in air molecules,
there was friction.
This energy will turn into heat.
A trend that you will see often in systems is,
that much more energy is converted into heat,
instead of useful work.
When the billiard balls move,
friction with the air will turn some of their kinetic energy
in thermal energy.
There will also be friction with the soft surface of the table.
In doing so, we will have molecules that rub off each other,
friction will turn into heat.
Since kinetic energy is reduced by friction,
we have the conversion of kinetic energy into heat.
Finally, we will not have more kinetic energy.
What about this weightlift here?
He uses chemical energy
in ATP molecules in your muscles that turns into
kinetic energy that drives his muscles.
This energy moves the burden. But when he reaches this position,
what happens to the energy?
A lot of it is now becoming
in potential energy. This enormous burden
is over his head and if he let go,
which I do not advise him to do,
this thing will fall very quickly.
Now much of the energy is stored as a potential energy.
But we also created warmth.
His muscles have generated heat.
Even if it's just in the air
creates heat in the air and friction with it.
I want you to remember that energy
does not come from nothing, it is becoming
from one form to another or carried
from one part of the system to another.
We can now look at these examples.
The same happens with our runner here.
Its chemical energy
allows his muscles to move, turns
in kinetic energy for his whole body, his whole body moves.
But at some point he stops. Where does the energy go?
Part of it will become warmth in his body,
which will dissipate in the whole system, in the air.
Besides, when it runs, it has contact with the ground.
This makes the molecules in the ground glare lightly.
Part of these vibrations will become a sound.
Part of the energy of the air particles,
who are on the move will turn into heat.
We will see this situation over and over again.
The diver above here has mostly potential energy.
Then it becomes kinetic energy,
when it almost reaches the water.
But what happens when it falls into the water?
Energy will surrender
of the receding water waves.
Also friction will increase.
We had friction and as it fell, which would produce heat.
Heat will also be generated when friction with water.
We usually do not think about friction with water, but there is one.
There are also waves that have greater kinetic energy
from the water itself, this energy is transmitted out
from the point of falling.
I can continue with the examples.
We have chemical potential energy in the fuel.
When ignited, it becomes heat
and radiant energy associated with fire.
It does not disappear, it radiates out.
The rays of energy radiate outward,
maybe to warm up something.
And the heat will be radiated out
or it will be distracting outside,
to warm the environment.
The same happens in the example of the flash.
We start with electrical potential,
the bottom of the clouds is more negative,
but the earth is positive.
At some point this potential energy turns
in kinetic energy as the electrons move through the air.
Then much of it
turns into heat and radiant energy.
The purpose of this video, regardless of the example,
was to show that if we think carefully,
I encourage you to do it every day,
we see that energy does not come from nothing,
does not appear with a magic wand, but simply turns from one species to another.